[Music]
all right welcome to cloud on-air live
webinars from Google cloud we're hosting
webinars every Tuesday
my name is Tyler alongside Roche and
today we're gonna be talking about G
sweet meeting solutions just a reminder
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have Googlers on
stand-by on standby to answer them so
let's get started
I think one caveat as we start is this
is gonna be a pretty high-level
introductory overview to G sweet meeting
solutions so feel free to ask questions
if you'd like a deep dive or we're happy
to to shoot us a note we can set up a
separate session for you all right so I
guess to set the stage and talk about
context a little bit as to why are we
here we talked to a lot of customers
today we see that they're really having
trouble communicate across departments
and different teams you know if you
think more and more folks are working
from different cities or different
countries it's getting increasingly
common for people to work from home once
in awhile or even if you're on a
business trip it makes sense that you
wanna be able to connect with the rest
of your team
and get things done not just be focused
on kind of the travel I'm separate part
of the trip you know one interesting
stat is 50 percent of the workforce may
be working remotely in some capacity by
2020 according to a Fast Company article
and it's not just Google or our
customers who see this but if you survey
kind of a broader group of managers or
IT or different analysts they're seeing
the same trends and a lot of folks are
worried one of the biggest obstacles
they face today is how do you
communicate across departments so how do
you get your marketing team to talk to
your product team or to your sales team
and our today's technologies and tools
keeping pace with that and so I'll go
into kind of our detailed solutions in a
minute but this is kind of those
problems but lots companies are facing
is the approach we're trying to take
with G suite how do we empower teams and
people to do their most impactful work
and so two principles we think about
with that or one how can you make things
together so how can our tools help you
collaborate with others but while not
sacrificing on speed how can you make
things fast so your tools kind of get
out of the way and help you collaborate
and way you're used to not kind of
inventing a whole new process
and so that's where our you cast our
unified communications offerings come
into play so I'll do a brief intro on
each of these in case you're new to G
suite or haven't heard of these before
but all of them our goal is to help
customers communicate with colleagues
customers and partners from anywhere to
get things done
so a brief intro hangout to meet and the
top left that's our video conferencing
app so basically effective video
meetings from anywhere hangouts chat
that's our team chat and direct message
tool and platform Google Voice we won't
go into as deep today but that's for
kind of telephony and communicating with
other colleagues ear OSHA and I will
talk a little bit later but our hardware
offerings as well at the bottom there's
hang out to meet hardware so that's kind
of dedicated video conferencing
equipment to get a great room with
reliable sound and video
and finally jam board if you're
interested Digital whiteboarding how do
people from different locations work
together seamlessly so I'm going to get
a brief overview talk about chat and
then pass it over to eros
but overall principles why you'd want to
use these kind of tools one is it can
really transform or change the way you
work before for example if you needed
for a project three review cycles you
might be able to cut that to one or two
if you're able to just jump on a video
conference or solve something over chat
quickly and others these tools are
actually deeply integrated into G Suites
you're not having to learn a whole new
system these things work with your
existing gmail or calendar or with your
kind of Docs and file storage like Drive
thirdly they're built for the enterprise
so for large customers most of these are
these products are available globally
across a bunch of countries they have
we've really high standards for security
and reliability and then finally you can
try them at no additional cost range so
they come with your existing G suite
subscription so we think it's really
compelling to help your teams
collaborate and communicate in a
different way so like I mentioned I'm
going to go over a briefly chat so
there's three components we think about
what hangouts chat can offer for
customers one is pretty self-explanatory
direct messages so you can kind of ping
or message anybody just to get a quick
or something but there's also dedicated
rooms you can think of them as spaces
for certain topics or certain teams to
communicate and get things done and then
finally thinking about the bot platform
integrations so in addition to chat can
you add more functionality or kind of
workflows and use cases as you're kind
of communicating with those others to
get things done so here's a kind of
screenshot or gif of what chat looks
like I'll do a brief walkthrough if you
haven't tried it before on the left-hand
side that's where you can see things
organized by either rooms or people so
this is what a lot of our customers kind
of their home base for the day everyday
where you can ping a person to get an
answer to something or there's the
specific project or topic rooms so for
example there's a marketing room where
you can discuss things with the rest of
the marketing team or we can jump in a
sales and marketing room to get a
broader set of people so that's kind of
how its organized and the core content
you're seeing is just a deep dive into
one room that's called marketing room
what's interesting about this is it's
organized by threads almost like you'd
be used to in Gmail so you can have
within one room separate topics so it's
very easy to kind of scan different
information and find the answer what you
need quickly I lead her to this earlier
but there's also a bot platform which
has some really interesting integration
so you can do more than just chatting
with people for example here on the left
hand side you can see how you might
within chat just create a port ticket
and assign it to somebody without
needing to open that app separately
similarly chats great for sharing files
so there's a box integration so you can
quickly share your q4 roadmap that was
stored within box or finally here's an
example where if you want to jump onto
an audio conference with RingCentral you
can do so right within the chat
interface I mentioned this earlier but
all these features in chat are globally
available at no additional cost
so we're localizing 28 languages
currently you can support up to 8,000
people in a chat room which is I think
more than you never need or else it
might get distracting there's kind of a
full-screen web experience but
also dedicated apps for Android iOS and
even back in Windows clients as well
and Google's always been a big believer
and accessibility so we have screen
reader support across kind of a range of
platforms today to really feel like any
team can adopt this right when they
start kind of implementing chat so that
was a brief kind of high-level overview
and chat deep dive I'm gonna pass it
over to Roche to talk more about actual
meeting solutions thanks oh yeah so
we're kind of like hangout chat which is
our enterprise collaboration tool now
let's talk about meet which is our video
conferencing solution 4G suite customers
a couple of ideas that meet is built on
is that it's easy to join high quality
video and audio and you can join you
from any device such as web browser
meeting room mobile app that it's
richard features and so on into any meet
launch in 2017 and in 2018 you made huge
strides to make making more enterprise
to cover more use cases so some reasons
why you should consider adopting meet in
your organization azar now we have even
larger meetings than before that means
up to a hundred full participants so
anybody can speak anybody can share and
present and you can stream a meeting up
to a hundred thousand viewers and I'll
go into more details on each of these
later on
second is interoperability so we know
that a lot of our customers have is this
thing we see a hardware in place and
they don't want to give up that
investment if they should switch to a
new meeting solution so that's when to
interpret Bailey interoperability
between needs and other solutions comes
into place and third is G suite
integrations so the biggest value of
using G suite tools with other G suite
products that you already have is
business processes that are built in and
flow seamlessly from one application to
another so larger meetings I set a
hundred full participants which is going
to cover most of your collaboration use
cases if you have more than 100 people
speaking a meeting maybe you should
schedule an outside but if you're
looking to connect the people from all
around the world a global offices
scheduled a town-hall even stream like a
conference that's very live streaming
can can help you it supports up to
100,000 viewers through our YouTube
video infrastructure but with security
and SLA off the G suite enterprise SLA
it's very easy to set up you don't need
IT to intervene here you just go to
calendar your schedule normal meeting
and you just turn on a live screen for
it it's as easy as that then you have to
share the the live stream link we do 10
days and that's it I mean it comes to
inter parity think about Cisco polycomb
devices that you see all around your
organization and then currently before
they were not be able to join a meet
meeting that means that if you're gonna
standardize a meet you would have to
slowly replace those we're talking about
thousands of dollars in lost investment
now we are participative you can
actually connect all of these units
including Skype for business as well
into a meet meeting and that's not just
a good pro organization it's also you
have third party partners on Cisco's and
Paula comes with Skype of business they
can join a meet meeting that you set up
through the same system without even
having to change how they how to use
this hardware and then integration
across suite so one thing as we develop
these tools we think about how do we
enable the whole lifecycle of a meaning
not just actually that's the
conversation so how do you prepare how
do you join a meeting how do you start
how do you make it more effective so
working with together working together
with g-suit solutions we we look at the
each of these areas so for preparing for
example smart scheduling is very rely on
calendar and hangouts chat in calendar
when your schedule you need to select a
room but a lot of times you don't know
the size of the room what kind of
equipment does it have what floor how
many people that sit so calendar has
these auto suggests and capabilities
very actually tell you this is the
closest room to you or the room you're
booked this is for enough people in that
office so you don't have to really think
about these details second one is Tyler
was talking about chat so sometimes you
want to chat with people around
something and then you realize that each
message it's actually making a situation
more confusing so you want to escalate
it into a videoconference because it's
substance it's easier to to get to our
conclusion
that way so we have something called
meet bot but it's gonna help schedule a
call find find the right time between
everybody who participates in this chat
and put it on your calendar so you don't
have to think and go back between the
tools when to schedule and what's the
people's availability in terms of
engagement during a meeting if you use
meet before you had only one layout you
could see the speaker or you could see
the presentation that something's gonna
change beginning of next year where we
are introducing adaptive layouts the
whole idea is that we know what kind of
meeting that is is somebody presenting
and who's presenting so we should show
the presentation and the speaker is
there a presentation and multiple people
having a conversation there we're gonna
show both the deck and the people who
are procore talking if it's a bunch of
you in a room just sharing a
presentation of the screen we won't show
any presenters at all it's gonna be just
one huge focus on a presentation so
basically we are using some basic
machine learning models to make meetings
more effective and engaging in terms of
assistance we are looking to use a lot
of our machine learning and voice
commands that you know with assistant
but also in the enterprise as well so
for customers with hangouts mean
Hardware of your introducing voice
actions so hey Google start a meeting or
hey Google take notes or hey Google
booked this room for under 30 minutes if
it's free the second thing is
integration with Docs which transforms
Doc's from a powerful powerful document
editing tool into the best meeting
note-taking tool so that's how you can
track your agenda your action items and
and and take notes
this helps meeting more productive and
get everybody start the next meeting
faster and more efficient when it comes
to brainstorming you've probably heard
about jam board which is our
award-winning digital whiteboard it
enables remote teams to collaborate on
an unstructured content so drawing
getting in images really really trying
to be creative and really getting to
coming together to bring new ideas
without having to travel and without
having to be in person Jam board is
completely connected to your GP domain
you can share you can continue you can
send
you can actually export them and
continue on where you're left off we
also have mobile and tablets
applications for jam boards so you're
not limited just to the actual physical
device and all of these solutions are
built for enterprise I think it's very
important to emphasize that even with
the live stream larger meetings with
Chambord it completely adheres to the
Google G suite SLA so two-factor
authentication
we control third-party access to
meetings pretty strictly and if you do
not invite third party people to your
meetings they're not gonna be able to
access or if you do not allow access
they're not gonna be able to be part of
it completely 35 for HIPAA gdpr is Osaka
nother I don't under a standard that you
would expect them to me so to summarize
a little bit what what Tyler and I were
talking about is these tools are
primarily the biggest values are they
transforming how you work they move
mundane tasks from email or reduce time
to join a meeting or make it easier for
people to collaborate and then they're
deeply integrated into G suite so your
business process or day-to-day habits
actually are this becomes part of your
day-to-day habits and make it makes as
much more streamlined to collaborate
together built for enterprise slided I
just mentioned so secure security
compliance in G suite SLA and then
finally these are free to anybody who's
a G speed customer so no additional cost
and you don't need to have any point
solutions that are gonna cover any of
these use cases so how to start what's
next we have a couple of starter guides
for hangouts meet a hangouts chat that
you can check out and this is how you
vote for admins and the end user so if
the admin wants to try out meet or chat
in their organization how to set it up
how to promote it second thing is if
you're a user and you have meet and chat
enabled how to start and where to
actually go and how to learn more about
using these solutions and then if you
need any more deep time on our Hardware
offerings on our software offerings you
can contact the meeting pod at this
email and they'll be happy to assist you
that with further information and with
that
stay tuned for live Q&A we will be back
in less than a minute
you
you
all right welcome back to cloud on air
we took a short break but now we have
some questions coming in so we're gonna
answer these for you
so I'll kind of moderate and only answer
a few and pass some Desroches so the
first one what are the benefits of an
integrated video meeting tool versus a
standalone one gross do you want to
speak to this yeah that's a great
question so like I said before one be
focused food meat is supporting a whole
lifecycle of a meeting so how you
prepare how you engage how do you follow
up how do you make meetings more
effective and that's why the
integrations with G suite are very
important think about note-taking
scheduling meetings finding time
escalating from chat to meet it's very
important that all these things save
time to your on your day to day basis
with a standalone solution you actually
have to integrate that standalone
solution into your existing ecosystem
first of all that's costly and it's
actually never the you're never a be
your neighbor able to do it to the full
extent that you actually need it so
standalone solution can be costly or
maybe they satisfy a specific niche use
case and that's why you keep them but
integrating ones definitely bring more
value to the table
cool thanks the next two are related I
think a little more tactical so I'll
take second one to give you the first
one so first one is how many attendees
does hang out to me support a single
call right so going back to the slides
from before 100 full participants of
people who can actually join participate
by speaking or presenting and up to a
hundred thousand viewers for livestream
so the only mode right and relatedly how
many people can be in one chat thread at
one time I believe the numbers currently
at eight thousand so basically you can
support really large teams or
essentially a whole organization
communicating in one thread okay the
next question is hang out to meet
hardware necessary or can I just use my
laptop and phone
that's a good question I'll take this
one would feel free to add more color if
you want so you can use hangout to meet
just on your laptop or phone it's free
as a part of G suite and it works pretty
well especially you know if you're just
taking a one-on-one meeting your laptop
can work great or on-the-go in an
airport your phone is a really useful
client we found most customers
especially larger ones really enjoy the
dedicated room hardware
just to have a room that's always
working and ready to go you also do get
a little bit higher quality of audio and
video and the visuals as it's dedicated
for that purpose whereas your smartphone
or laptop is trying to do a lot of
different things so we really encourage
it to help drive adoption and to have
the highest quality meetings possible
cool next question where can I learn
more about Jam board a few things here
one the email address we gave earlier in
the slides meeting room pod that'd be a
great team to shoot a note to if you
have specific questions but also you can
just google the word jam board and we
have a lot of online resources and
websites to help you learn more there
was a related question as Jam board free
with a part of G suite
the answer to this one's a bit twofold
the dedicated hardware is an additional
cost but you can actually download the
mobile app or tablet app for free so I
encourage you to try that play with it
to see if you like it and want to learn
more cool it next question are there
tools or training for IT to help with
adoption of hangout to meet and chat
your rush to you yeah that's a good one
so here refers to one of the previous
slides we do have some starter packs and
how to start with meat and how to start
a chat so they do focus on the IT admin
they're going to show you how to enable
it for your domain how to rule it out
the best practice we've seen is to
probably probably roll it out for a
smaller subset of your domain maybe your
IT organization start adopting start
integrating with your third-party
systems and then roll it out from there
got it that make sense and last question
do these features also apply to
customers of G suite for education I
know this presentation was more
Enterprise focused a rush what do you
think yeah it's a good question so all
of these features do apply to Jesus
before education reform meet we do have
customers and education that are
streaming classes live over meat and
that complete transformed the way they
do online education Chambord is
something that's being used in education
as well and then customers who actually
do have a lot of meeting internal
meetings of meat they actually use
hangouts meat harder as well for their
meeting roles all right well thank you
for sending your questions really
appreciate it that's all for today
please tune in I believe next week for
the next cloud on-air
you
you